[Music]
aaron is with us from seattle washington
and aaron
you were on the show the other day and
the way this works
is kelly puts the calls up in an order
and they're color coded
and i just screwed it up and i went to
the wrong color
and that meant i got out of order and
then you had to go to work
yeah yeah that's right because evidently
making money or whatever is more
important than being on the show which
is ridiculous but whatever
aaron no man i'm so sorry brother i
screwed up dude i'm sorry
no that's all good it was it was more
that driving
to work i i i entered uh some roaming
areas so do not roam and be on this show
it's just not worth you paying for this
stuff for sure
this is this is a free transaction
absolutely man
hey how can i help dude good to talk to
you
thanks for taking my call dr dalonia i
really appreciate it
um i i'm i am having some
trouble uh navigating
how to choose my wife and honor my
mother um
yeah tell me more about that yeah so
seems like you can do both of those what
am i missing
sorry um about um
about sorry one second
about three years ago my my father
passed away
from a rare degenerative brain disease
um we all had seasons of caring for him
but you know my mom really took care of
him until the end
after that my wife and i made a real
conscious effort
to um to to be there for her
to to you know have her come out to
visit
and um you know fast forward to
today and and my mom she really wears
a lot of that neediness on her sleeve
and and it just feels like
you know nothing can ever be enough and
it can be really abrasive
especially for my wife who isn't used to
you know personality quirks and whatnot
and so
um the the trouble comes
when i i find myself
defending my
mom's intentions over my wife's or
advocating for uh her and and
my wife has felt really hurt by the way
that i've handled
um this relationship and i just i don't
i don't know how to do those two things
well
dude thanks for thanks for trusting me
with that um
is your wife right like just being
honest just two guys is your wife right
yes yeah she's she's yeah have you told
her
you're right no sorry and i don't know
what to do
um yes okay and she she's asked me to
talk to people
so so backing up to your mom she lost
her husband she lost her co-pilot
and sounds like it was a
long slow burn which is a really painful
way to see somebody go
and in the meantime a lot of people
rallied around her
is that right um
no not so much i feel like with the long
slow burns
people don't know how to
people don't know how like you know how
long do i bring this up for you know uh
they just don't know how to be around
uncomfortable situations where you're
right
or where the other person's in diapers
and the other person's bedridden and you
so no i didn't feel like a lot of people
rallied around
in the heat of that situation there's
one or two that
stick around and you know that they're a
good friend but
yeah so fast forward a couple of years
this is several years ago
when you say she's you've got to
apologize for she's
not being um she's not pleasant she's
got
anytime a son says my mom's got
personality quirks that means mom's not
being cool
and you're trying to find a nice
respectable way to say like my mom's
really hard to be around so when you say
she's got quirks
she's tough you have to apologize and
explain what does that mean give me some
give me some examples
yeah so it's it's mostly in it's in
moments where
my wife and my mother
don't get along and um it it really does
seem like
like personality clashes where um
my my mom is actually really
kind of cheery in-your-face person
loud and um and
her and my wife just don't don't get
along and so when it comes to things
like
how often should she visit or how long
or where should she stay
you know my wife is um
she draws these pretty heavy boundaries
um
it's not just personality differences
it's my wife
um or sorry my my wife has drawn these
boundaries and she feels like my mom
continues to cross them so this doesn't
sound like
grief issues and so
one common misconception is people who
are grieving deeply can be jerks too
right that doesn't i thought that's what
this call was that doesn't sound like
that that sounds like your mom wants to
come visit and hang out and your
wife doesn't like your mom and so she
says mom can't stay here i don't want
mom around
is that is that more the issue yeah
yeah i think i was i was equating the
grief with neediness
um and we have the monopoly on
grandchildren
right now and and so she always wants to
come and visit the grandkids and
so why doesn't your wife like your mom
because she's cheery
i see so i thought this call was i
thought you were calling to say my mom
is constantly calling us and crying and
you don't care about me and why do you
love her over
me and you just abandoned me and
i'm still grieving like that doesn't
sound like the case sounds like mom just
wants to
is lonely and she wants to come hang out
with grandkids even if she's not lonely
she's once come see your grandkids wants
to come see you guys
and your wife doesn't like her why why
doesn't she like her
yeah um so for for a couple years
that was the case that my wife really
didn't
didn't feel like she liked my mom she
had said that and
she's recently had a change of heart and
and
she kind of recognized that my mom isn't
necessarily a problem
but it's when there are
relational issues when there are
boundaries crossed because i have been
quick to defend my mom my wife doesn't
feel like she can be totally transparent
with me
and she doesn't feel like she can bring
to me oh you know
your mom did this this really annoying
thing
with the kids and and you know i this
thing i really didn't like or she said
i'm
this thing and so aaron feel like she
can aaron your mom's not the problem
you and your wife are having some
challenges right
yes yeah yes mom has become a
cool easy outside target for your wife
because she doesn't know how to deal
with you
yeah well i i feel it's you know me
um what is it man there's something
bigger that you're not telling me
like what what is the relational
fracture between you and your wife
you've got little kids you're exhausted
you're not showing up
your wife has changed like what what is
it there's something bigger than mom
um
yeah i i've kind of
felt like they were a bit unrelated
you know i i just felt like it's kind of
this
um
my tendency to um defend my mom and
and um it's not man your mom has become
a way that your wife can try to talk to
you
without attacking you
and so that that's your sounds like it's
your wife
trying to get your attention without
coming after you do you take feedback
well
or do you shut down are you a shutdown
guy
um you think i've become a
shutdown guy okay if your wife gets
pissed at you
do you go into neutral do you fight back
like what do you what's your response
there
i go into neutral okay
so your wife knows i can't talk to you i
can't comment you i can't
have a healthy fight with you i can't
have conflict with you so we can work
through it because you go into neutral
until i'm not go after mom yeah
and you're there probably is some real
hurt
whether it's um justified or not
right you lost your dad and that's hard
how long have you all been married
uh five years yeah man so learning how
someone you love
grieves is always messy it's always
messy
my wife and i had to deal with that too
uh she lost a really close family member
a couple years after we got married i
didn't get it
i didn't understand it i grieved
differently i thought she was grieving
too hard i didn't know what i know now
and so we had to learn how each other
grieves and there was some pain
associated with that she thought i was
insensitive and she was right and i
thought she was
so we had to figure that out you you
had the misfortune the heartbreak and
the challenge of you got married and
then a couple years in
um your dad's body began to shut down on
him and then he passed away
and y'all are still figuring out
marriage figuring out young kids and now
you're figuring out how to grief
and by the way my mom's grieving too so
you're in the middle of this thing right
so
that's something that every young couple
has to work out that's part of it but
there's something bigger here
whether you haven't dealt with your dad
whether you haven't dealt with
i don't think i like my wife because she
was mean to me when i was hurting
whatever that is
you all got some major relational
fractures that i'm worried about and
then your poor mom
is just what's coming out their
grandkids and she's become the
the scapegoat here so let me ask you
this do you love your wife
i do do you like her there's a
difference there
yeah i i feel like 90
of the time it's it's wonderful and and
then
we hit these ruts and
for you know a month or so we don't like
each other
are you a when you go into neutral
let me ask it this way are you violent
with your silence
yes do you become a very heavy presence
in your house
yeah i did and you'd never hit her or
scream at her
but you'll just slowly drown the house
in that
i my wife calls it sunday afternoon dad
but just that
hulking you know what i mean
yeah yep yeah
that's me yeah so don't do that man
don't drown your wife in silence
and you all are in desperate need and
i'm telling you this from personal
experience man
i did this for 10 years 15 years i got
so self-righteous
i would never scream i don't yell i
don't smash stuff
i don't fill in the blank i would never
be abusive i don't raise my voice
but dude i could
just be violent with silence
and avoidance and whatever then fine
and yeah i left my wife out there on an
island screaming and yelling and waving
flags saying will you help me
will you talk to me nope cool man
whatever dude you know what i mean
so here's what y'all are desperate nita
how old are your little kids
uh we've got three in three years
good gosh dude yes of course
so just back up for a second the last
five years by the way if you ever call
somebody else for help lead with that by
the way
you've got did i have that i have three
kids in three years yes
in a five-year-old marriage and by the
way dad slowly died
in this process and then my mom
slowly grieved drowned with it drowned
she drowned with him
and then stuck her hand up and i was the
guy
you guys have had a lot in five years a
lot
yeah yeah y'all are exhausted you're
fried out
y'all used to just go be silly and
reckless and i bet you used to be fun is
my guess
i bet you were a blast i was a blast for
sure
and your wife remembers that guy yeah
and are you all like deep and thoughtful
and you're like oh what about this and
you got like thoughts on bitcoin and
stuff is that you
surprisingly accurate i knew it and i
bet your wife
you see look that's the guy she married
and here's the thing
that's the guy you are and you've heard
me say this a hundred times i'm gonna
say it a thousand times more until they
take the show off the year
but listen you all gotta get away
and you gotta just look your wife in the
eye and say i have sucked and i'm sorry
now to my defense dad died we got three
kids i love you
but this has been chaos and i haven't
done this right
and we cannot go back and edit yesterday
all we can do is hold this pen and start
writing new sentences for tomorrow and
it's going to start with excavating the
site you've heard my twin towers analogy
you cannot take
what's happening is you're waiting for
things to get back to the way they used
to be
and she's waiting for things to get back
to the way they used to be and you can't
because
there is no going back you got three
kids under three
you all are on the annual sex plan and
every time you do it you have a kid
right it's a little better than that but
yes
it's not you can it's just america it's
they're fine they get it too they're all
there too
but listen you all have to have to get
away and look at each other and say
i am still in and i've got a lot of
growing to do i've got a lot of
apologizing to do i've got a lot of
saying i'm sorry and i need to learn
some new skills and she does too
the mom isn't the issue y'all are
exhausted and fried and cooked
you cannot take all that metal and all
that glass and all of the
smoke and dust and rebuild the twin
towers you can't
you got to excavate the whole site get a
new architect get new engineers
dream big and then rebuild something new
and it's going to
suck aaron it's going to be hard but
here's the deal right now sucks and it's
hard isn't it
yeah yes so choose the hard
choose the the difficult path that is
fun and romantic and has sex
and laughs a lot and listens to music
and your stupid theories on bitcoin and
whatever
um go back to that or create something
new don't go back create something new
to that
dance in your living room man decide
that you're gonna love this woman
and then there's gonna be moments when
your mom wants to come visit
and then you need to talk to your wife
about hey
mom needs to see your grandkids that's a
thing that's gonna happen
i turn into an idiot help me
be a better husband when my mom is here
what do you need from me
and i guarantee you she's got a list
that's different than
well mom this and how can i honor you
when my mom is here and then you're
gonna go tell your mom
that and your mom is gonna think you're
the greatest husband ever
wow and my mom i mean my mom my wife
sends emails to our family hey here's
the schedule here's who's sleeping where
and that helps everybody's there and we
love it right but it's just negotiating
and learning and talking to each other
and i will be honest with you brother
your marriage is on the ropes these are
tough tough seasons
so this is sos time the alarms are going
off
um you step into the gap here man
start with i'm sorry stop what i've
blown it stop start with
we're gonna rebuild this thing dude i'm
so
excited for what this is gonna turn into
i want you to call me back after you
have this conversation with her you're
going to take her out we're going to do
a half day retreat
you and her hey can i chime in with
something yeah yeah what if there are
legit
boundary issues with mom that that are
being crossed as well
so if so this aaron this is james so if
there are legit boundary
issues you have to have the boundary
conversation with your spouse a great
question james you got to have the
boundary conversation with your spouse
outside of all this other stuff so a
part of
i'm all in i haven't been doing my end
right and she's gonna say i haven't
either and we're gonna
clean up the way we talk to each other
clean up what our marriage looks like
then we're gonna have a true boundary
conversation so the way i like to think
about that is
you can't build fence on lava on moving
rock you've got to let that stuff be
settled and then you can say here is our
boundaries
and then you have to communicate those
boundaries to mom
right and sometimes that boundary might
be hey mom we have a house
that's small it's a three-bedroom
two-bath house and we have three kids
under three
that all need to sleep they all need to
have these a solid routine
plus me and my wife plus plus plus we
need you to stay in a hotel we're gonna
pay for the first night you can stay as
long as you want we want you here at 8
a.m to come play but
here's our nap times we don't budge on
these we do
not feed our kid these things we're
asking you
i'm asking you as your son to honor that
oh honey they can have twinkies
not in my house right and there comes a
moment when if mom crosses those
boundaries that's a whole separate phone
call it's a whole separate conversation
um and there may be a moment when you
say you can't be on the kids because
we've asked you and you're not honoring
our boundaries
i don't think that's the case here but
yeah it's a great question james but i
don't want people building boundaries
because what happens is you end up
building boundaries
against your spouse to punish your
spouse not because of a mom issue
right great question man look at that
question in a question this is like a
russian doll episode here i love it
yeah just remember if one of those two
things can be true at the same time
that's exactly right situations but you
got to go you got to
make sure your your relationship is
healthy first and then start building
boundaries so you got to make sure your
ground is stable before you start
putting fences up right
hey thank you so much for that call
aaron call me back after your half day
retreat with your wife i got to know how
it goes
um my gut tells me it's going to go
great and maybe i'll just take a half
day you'll meet for two hours and you'll
just go take a nap for a couple of three
hours
that would be awesome